wie oder was geht ab hier soll max und
herzukommen zu dieser runde get down wir
werden probieren heute einen kleinen
change zu machen und zwar wollen wir mit
dem enterhaken bzw mit hilfe des
enterhaken zu gewinnen indem wir leute
hochziehen oder von ihrem rücktritt von
anklam werde er lud also wir sind
sozusagen so richtige piraten neue
chance dahin erst mal also bis zum
zeitpunkt wo wir dann die change
eigentlich spielen also deathmatch werde
ich einfach relativ viele points sammeln
wenn es klappt irgendwie habe ich es
klappt nicht aber wir probieren sie
einmal aus wir müssen irgendwie was weiß
ich halt auch was einstecken können weil
durch die ganzen extra herzen man könnte
es auch natürlich mit rüstung machen
aber ich werde natürlich zu einfach kann
man dann halt auch niemand von einem
anständigen schwert oder so was
einstecken
spätestens dann denke ich mal wenn wir
sind durch flugzeug von irgendjemand
anders können wir dann wahrscheinlich
relativ gut spielen weil wenn wir jetzt
irgendwie was ich mit 1501 oder sowas
die runde abschließen dann dürfte es
machbar sein dass wir da irgendwie
selbst mit nicht so krank gutem
equipment dann halt irgendwie 30 hertz
namen oder so und dann über die herzen
und seinen vorteil haben das ist
natürlich erst mal bis zu dem zeitpunkt
wo wir das equipment haben echten
schwierige sache und ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob es klappt aber ich hoffe sehr
und werde kein sammeln und das waren
natürlich nice leute dieser springen
effekt ist irgendwie der übelste denen
ich den es überhaupt gibt finde ich aber
es hat einfach direkten teil über dem
kopf das sowieso das beste wenn man
diese ganzen negativen effekte kriegs
und irgendwie voll hatten direkt einen
blog unter ams oder springen wären
direkt einer übung ist und ich sage
immer voll voll geht immerhin aber
spring geht nicht weil wir spielen ja
nicht des jahreszeiten spielt bildes
liegt am server die sind nicht sind
nicht konstant in ihrer
sprachwahl deshalb mache ich das falsch
also besucht mich die schuld bei mir
eigentlich sucht sie bei anderen 4145
zweite runde nicht so super gut
aber eigentlich ist es schon gut aber
baum des lebens david verdammt schwer
auf die 1500 zu kommen oder so die ich
mir als ziel gesetzt habe
das habe ich in puglia ist ja voll geil
abonnieren muss man den kaufen aber
nicht den puls abonniert den alten kram
ich selbst gerne ganze weile nicht mehr
an
sollte recht auf finnischen spielen
leute aber das wird auch nicht zu mehr
verdammt wollte 150 hat längst nicht die
möglichkeit so viele kontakte zu
bekommen wie ich eigentlich gerne hätte
auch wegen der übelkeit bin jetzt
tatsächlich gestorben ich war auf dem
tollen blog auf dem block hinter mir und
es hat sich so gedreht dass sie dachte
ich falle und da wollte ich mich
irgendwie noch bewegen dass sie auf
einen block im runterfallen kommen mit
welchen gehabt als 2000 seiten gab es
1000 22 aber jetzt kommt es zum
eigentlich kritischen pfad
das wird nämlich alles was ich mir jetzt
kauft und dann sehen wir uns vielleicht
in das match wieder so leute sind jetzt
im set match die karte ist eigentlich
relativ glücklich falls er fragt wo
sebastian hin ist der besuch etwas für
unsere mama und ich werde jetzt
probieren oben auf die bridge zu gehen
von dort oben die acht vermisste er
wieder das ohne wird sich unsere mutter
der so eine ganz üble angewohnheit immer
rein zu platzen dann nicht aus dem raum
zu gehen weil sie am lkw sind youtube
wir müssen aufnehmen nein ich muss genau
jetzt die reihe muss mich jetzt eine
halbe stunde hier aufhalten und laut
sein so dargestellt dafür aber ich habe
gesagt okay du raus ich wohl etwas zu
holen willst jetzt habe ich gefunden
ziemlich schnell so ist gerade pünktlich
raus bugsiert okay gut wir haben 30 hat
das ist eigentlich schon ein ganz cooler
zahl ja ja
leben liebe
du kleine nutzen
das war dass er locker nicht überlebt
das hat er nicht überlebt ihr unter die
runde geholt das wäre jetzt der absolute
wahnsinn wenn alles über die platte hat
es nicht will aber dann dann hätten wir
ja oder ja
junge junge junge junge junge finden da
ist es den gips 30 hertz und rüstung 30
ärzten rüstung infiniti bogenbauer vier
freunde damit sind wir op
damit junge jetzt die 32 herzen mit
goldie an die wand mit goldie wanzen
scheint 32 30 so leute aber wir haben
die challenge quasi geschafft also wir
haben jetzt richtig gutes zeug jetzt hol
dir den bodenkampf schaffen es dreist
auch stabil angebracht
1385 eigentlich war mir war so mein plan
immer gewesen ich dachte okay
irgendwie da unten beispielsweise läuft
in einer vorbei
zack hochziehen und dann fällt er halt
irgendwie 100 plätze runter oder sowas
eines instant daun
aber das war eigentlich genau dasselbe
nur dass ich im alten teils mit der hand
gegeben hat vorne sind zwei gegners wir
machen doch einmal weiter wenn die cic
geradezu schleift 30 erst recht nicht
ein bisschen zu knapp hahaha schade das
ist irgendwie so ein bisschen so eine
assassinen challenge piraten immer so
auf dem bogen ziele ist einfach mein
erkennungsmerkmalen
weil ich halt immer im vorbeiziehen
erhalten bleibt die bleibt bleibt er und
und als er erst über dem viertel kommt
man so kopf es ist der dekan bekommen
aber er ist auch ein relativ gut
gefallen aber so kannst du jetzt
ordentlich schaden machen als playboy
daraus daraus der ausdauer alter schwede
was da so kannst du dir auch selbst
retten impflücken kampf hat hier ein gut
einsetzen wollten am sonntag und da ist
er ja wohl heute hat nicht mehr viel
gebraucht hätten ja der hat er noch
nicht mehr fiebert leute ist
funktioniert dies ist aber jetzt ist
erst mal googeln extra com/blog sie alle
mit der anleiter müssen wir erstmal
einfach jeden zumindest ihren rassismus
ich mit der angel man glück hat halt
sogar mit kämpfen fallen gerade hier
oben auf diesem teilen aber momentan
kann sich auch theoretisch muss nur die
angel in die mitte werfen ihn dann mit
der hand mit einer angel in der hand
schlagen
seit jahren wieder eine million stück
saarland prozent wieder ein
die post sei es sowieso eine
rettungsleine für den fall dass order
fans aber ziehen
leute ich kann einfach mal ein
wunderschöner tag wieder reparieren und
ist es nur ein fashion or if label
nächste junge ich dachte jetzt stören
könnte das ist ja wohl in die neue
holding putin weiß was ich fange jetzt
runter mit der an ihn ran und dann zu
hoch einfach vor es kann mach das schon
30 jahre her dass die rezepte rw ist
halt der nächste nicht der letzte
spieler der zuvor hinter dem städtischen
klicks tour gedacht die auf die andere
seite ziehen auf der einen seite rüber
gehen quasi und jetzt sind wir aufrecht
als aufgeholt der bluttat ist direkt an
ich habe mich am hintern hoch hitze
irgendwas
dahinter folgen 30 herzen alter leute
wir machen dort ungefähr jeden kill
einfach mit dem enterhaken das ist eure
schreibt geschichte ja das ist das echte
die wieder mal ich hätte niemals gedacht
dass es so funktioniert wie wir er
anerkennt die kinderkirche die kraft
oder ja ich habe halt ahnung von der
kraft her ohne wird von der kraftraum
auf handwerk ja maria intakte an
gerettet und acer will etwas war ich gut
kritik wir haben drei es ist zumindest
zu macht mit dem entpacken der dutt
wollte unsere taktik kopieren
ich hoffe mal dass ihr euch nicht alle
in den nächsten gipfeltreffen wir
probiert diese taktik nach zu machen
weil das ganze ziemlich nervig sein
aber das war es einfach macht's guten
bist du nicht möglich